boa tarde a todos
é eu gostaria também dizer que é muito
melhor e tá aí do que o pac
o lugar de vocês é muito melhor do que o
meu mas vamos lá meu nome é fato mas
solto eu sou psicóloga por vocação mais
uma apaixonada pelas pessoas por opção
de vida e essa opção mísseis
muitas vezes caminhar através de
projetos e projetos sociais que eu nem
imaginava que ia acontecer porque a vida
da gente às vezes é ela se dirigissem a
gente perceber para um determinado
caminho e esse caminho às vezes provoca
mudança na vida de suas outras pessoas
que a gente nunca imaginava que
acontecesse mas antes de começar a
conversar com vocês
eu gostaria de saber quem aqui já viu
uma sereia sereia sereia naquelas que
têm metade mulher metade peixe
alguém já viu acho que a gente só viu em
livro o filme mas vocês podem acreditar
em mim eu conheci sereias e ouvir o
canto delas e elas me guiaram praia da
penha
chegando lá eu redescobrir a história da
penha a pesar e foi assim uma paixão
grande à segunda vista porque apesar de
morar em joão pessoa
eu nunca tenha olhado a praia da penha
com os olhos de uma sereia
agora eu olho pra praia da penha com os
olhos de ser e e as sereias
isso aí é uma imagem que eu
o morador de joão pessoa não conhece
porque a praga tenha quase invisível
apesar dela está dentro da cidade é
quase invisível mas é uma das
localizadas em uma
os mares mais bonitos do nosso litoral é
a pré da penha ainda um pouco selvagem
com habitantes nativos daquela
localidade e com a pressão imobiliária
terrível em cima dela mas a população
resiste bravamente e foi aí de cima que
é frei as trouxeram pra mim pela rede
dos seus maridos dos seus pescadores
a estamo que eu acho que vocês estão aí
com ela na mão e essa escama foi-me
trazida pelas sereias que viviam
adormecidas ainda acalentadas por aquele
mar muito bonito esperando uma
oportunidade uma única chance para serem
reconhecidas
quando eu segurei na mão esse pequeno
pedaço do corpo de um peixe que mais
parecia uma madre pérola
eu imaginei quanto às possibilidades
aquele pedacinho do corpo desse peixe
poderia se transformar
ela é lisa ela é transparente e tem um
brilho é maravilhoso e isso foi se
emaranhando na minha vida e foi gravada
no meu coração e se transformou a paixão
avassaladora
é eu gostaria que vocês sentirem a mesma
coisa que eu sinto
mas como a gente ia trabalhar como
agente iria fazer alguma coisa por essas
pessoas já tenha por essas é batalhadora
dessas mulheres bravas da pedra bem o
que quer como é que a gente podia fazer
sozinho ninguém faz nada e eu sempre eu
sou do ifpb eu sou da extensão do do
instituto federal de educação ciência e
tecnologia da paraíba ea gente trabalha
muito com projetos sociais e tentando
levar o instituto para fora dele e
atende a comunidade
mas o prostituto sozinho e eu sozinho a
gente não conseguiria fazer nada
foi quando eu conheci um grupo de jovens
de design gráfico quando nós fizemos o
primeiro
pimenta design acho que algum de vocês
já ouviram falar na experimenta design e
quando nós fizemos o experimento nós
trouxemos o design gráfico ronaldo fraga
por aqui pra dar um audioguia design
gráfico não perdão design de moda e
estilista ronaldo fraga e ele viu por um
acaso uma flor de escama de peixe
ele olhou aquele aquela flor ele se isso
aqui pode ser transformado em milhões de
produtos em produtos muito bonito me
calei a gente foi caminhando e me
deparei com um programa chamado joão
pessoa artesã da prefeitura municipal de
joão pessoa e com o sebrae
eu tinha três amigas pessoais nesses
três dessas três instituições e daí a
gente júnior força e cada uma trabalha
na instituição e construímos um pacto
fizemos um elo porque as instituições
enquanto elas trabalham sozinhas elas
não duplicam as forças
você quando trabalha com em parceria com
uma gestão compartilhada primeiro você
duplica a inteligência ou triplica você
duplica o capital humano e você do que
duplica tudo ea o que esse projeto é o
resultado desse projeto é com certeza um
resultado muito maior do que se uma
instituição trabalhar sozinho então as
três instituições é trabalharam juntas
primeiro o ifpb através do programa
pronatec mulheres mil
ele já fez uma oficina de capacitação em
biojóias durante três meses essas
mulheres a gente abriu inscrição para
quem quisesse durante três meses
elas foram capacitadas no manuseio da
escama é uma coisa muito importante pra
dizer pra vocês é que essa escama que
vocês eu acho que receberam algumas
alguma estava manuseando elas são de um
peixe chamado camurupim que só ocorre no
litoral do nordeste ele ocorre com mais
freqüência no litoral
o 10 em braço de rio de outubro a
dezembro
e aqui nós temos em uma certa abundância
no rio saia lá além da entrada do porto
e ele tem a carne dele não é não é uma
carne de primeira não é considerado uma
carne de primeira mas as suas escamas
são deslumbrantes e estas escamas antes
eram jogadas no lixo e hoje essas
escamas ela estão sendo vendidas a 100
reais o quilo
elas antigamente eram jogadas fora então
a arte na escola de peixe que vem dos
açores é uma arte que vem dos açores ela
chegou aqui no brasil e hoje a gente na
paraíba tem uma cadeia produtiva
interessante cima porque aquela escama
que era jogada no lixo hoje ela custa
r$100 até mais caro do que um quilo de
peixe
só que o que descama um saco enorme tal
bom é a oficina de biojóias aconteceu às
as artesãs foram capacitadas eram em
número de 40 foram capacitadas no
manuseio da escama depois disso é a
parceria possibilitou uma segunda
oficina porque o que é que o joão pessoa
artesã ea prefeitura municipal está
querendo com esse programa dá uma
identidade ao artesanato local porque
joão pessoa você quando vai na feira e
tambaú e em algum mercado de artesanato
você encontra produtos bons maravilhosos
uma arte maravilhosa mas não é a arte
específica da nossa cidade
se você vai por exemplo pra são bento às
redes de são bento são características e
tem identidade dessa dessa dessa
localidade
ah eu voltei a
e durante as oficinas nós fomos
aprendendo e construindo um elo em uma
história muito bonita é nós conhecemos a
história dele landra de josi de dorinha
de vitória de edna hoje eu tenho é
grande e as três filhas de regras já
estão conosco nós temos magna nós vemos
sebastiana
nós temos várias pessoas conosco e eu
não vou dizer o nome todo senão a lista
é enorme e nós descobrimos a história de
vida de cada um e nós nos tornamos
amigas e é quase uma família quando
mantém problema liga pra mim com o outro
tem problema liga pro pessoal do
sebrae/se é o elo que se criou foi tão
forte que hoje elas não estão mais só
trabalhando com abril jóia elas estão
interessadas em transformar a comunidade
delas é a terceira etapa do projeto eu
passei mais rápido foi a contratação do
design de moda ronaldo fraga ele veio a
joão pessoa para a qual ela dá um
eu digo que ele transformou a biojóias
no objeto de desejo é nós demos uma
capacitação aliás foram duas derrotas do
são paulo fashion week que eu não
acreditava quando as coisas aconteceram
não conseguia acreditar que aquilo fosse
verdade pra gente é um sonho impossível
a gente sair da penha ea gente saiu para
são paulo e nós saímos pra muitos outros
lugares porque tem encomenda até na
suíça na argentina hoje e o designer
ronaldo fraga ele deu uma visibilidade
enorme o projeto porque ele está
apresentando com a sua coleção que ele
chamou a fúria já serei eu não entendia
porque era a fúria da sereia
ele chamou fúria cerebral que ele diz
que a fúria da transformação e criou
também um elo com o nosso estado porque
ele disse que a paraíba é um estado na
arte do feito à mão carrega mágica da
poesia a alegria da música
ea força da literatura e essa vocação
foi a fonte de inspiração de todo o
projecto é um projecto inovador porque
ele respeita à sustentabilidade do nosso
planeta gerando renda e inclusão social
é esse aí estão as peças que as meninas
fazem com os croquis do design a o
croqui foi feito ea peça foi elaborada
logo depois aí é ele com uma diferença a
roupa que foi também remeteu amar esse
desfile aconteceu em abril
as meninas trabalhando com escama e é o
interessante desse projeto é que ele
criou uma metodologia pra mim pessoal
para o pessoal das outras instituições
porque a partir do momento que você
descobre a potencialidade criativa de um
de uma localidade de um bairro e isso
pode ser feito na cidade no estado num
bairro numa localidade pequena você
mobiliza você estabelece elos de
parceria porque é muito importante essa
parceria é nesse projeto num não busquei
é eu vos que inteligência de outras
instituições porque sozinho não vamos
conseguir nada nós qualificamos porque
essa é a minha grande e nós organizamos
a a fizemos a organização nas artesãs é
nós fizemos oficinas elas hoje estão com
a seleção formada com cnpj tem uma loja
participam de feiras e eventos
vocês lembram no começo quando eu
perguntei vocês se alguém já tinha visto
a ser e eu disse que já tinha visto os
encontrei
agora eu trouxe duas sereias eu gostaria
de chamar uma delas pra que elas
dissessem vocês um sentimento que elas
tiveram após esse projeto sem realizado
na penha josi por favor
josi josi por favor
josé a presidente da associação cereja
bank foi estabelecido agora e agora a
palavra dela
boa noite
eu me chamo joseane antes do projeto
seria da penha eu era dona de casa não
saía da minha casa basicamente para a
nave era cuidar de filho ou marido casa
fiz o ensino médio incompleto não
terminei porque virei dona de casa
nunca pensei em ser o que eu sou hoje
o projeto seria da pen transformou a
minha vida totalmente completamente
eu nunca pensei em fazer o que eu faço
hoje essas peças
nunca imaginei antes disso eu nunca
tinha ouvido falar na biojóias pra mim
existe a jóia pronto biojóias vez
transforma mestrado no curso desde o
começo
hoje estamos há um ano juntas
o projeto também senão a gente a
trabalhar em família a se importar com
as outras pessoas que geralmente a gente
não faz isso mas hoje eu tenho as
meninas como irmãs uma família fora
minha uma família que a gente se
preocupa com elas e melhorou a
autoestima hoje eu vejo elas eu também
se cuidando mais a gente se acha mais
bonita a gf se acha mulher coisa que não
acontecia antes o projeto é só levantada
na autoestima da gente também melhorou
bem dizer tudo na vida da gente a gente
nunca sonhou e sempre as áreas hoje a
gente já está caminhando sempre as
várias né
as conquistas foram grandes em um ano a
gente conseguiu uma loja
hoje somos associação temos cnpj e hoje
deu beijo elas fazendo planos para
crescer e isso me deixa muito feliz
eu gostaria também que mário gente eu tô
morrendo emocionado aconteceu isso
igualzinho do são paulo fashion week
porque quem acompanha o projeto desde o
começo e acompanha a história de vida
dessas mulheres guerreiras
a gente se emociona com a transformação
ocorrida na vida delas magra eu me chama
magna também faço parte desse esse grupo
e agora é uma associação que eu não
penso como a sensação fez como família
minha segunda família
pra mim foi maravilhoso está sendo até
hoje participar eu não sonhava sim eu
pensei que seria mais um curso curso na
penha
eu ia participar vai fazer mas que
achava muito bonito que eu já comecei a
pesquisar então eu vou fazer esse curso
vou fazer minhas coisas em casa e vou
vender pela internet
não pensava em mim minha sócia a outras
pessoas
então elas formaram o grupo e eu resolvi
entrar e me foi a melhor coisa que
aconteceu até hoje na minha vida foi a
melhor coisa que me aconteceu
a transformação foi imensa na minha vida
eu era uma simples babá
hoje sou uma empresária é promotora de
vendas sei eu sou tudo hoje eu artesiano
só artesato eu faço biojóias o
sou dona de casa também sou mãe também
mas sou artesã primeira e aqui com vocês
as sereias que eu conheci